my sister's murder was headline news for
years the whole world knows more than I
do
welcome to Indigo Bay
trust me you like it
admit that this Resort is incredible I'm
happy to be here if you want to move
who was that cutie you were talking to
tonight was my last night
I was hoping we could do something
special
[Music]
what is it sweetie no no Allison didn't
come home last night
oh honey I'm sure she's okay
multiple Witnesses saw Alison at the bar
last night with two young local men
let me be clear
we have determined
the death of Alison Thomas
was an accident
this was not an accident and everyone
knows it you know what's cool about
vacation nobody knows us this is our
chance to try on someone new
[Music]
my sister's murder was headline news for
years
sometimes it feels like the whole world
knows more than I do
you need to get some help because at
this point you've become a stalker
my sister was murdered
that is the only thing that matters
[Music]
are looking for us all right when you
ask about the girl we never saw her
again you understand me I am having such
a good time with your family
I need to keep doing this
for her